good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having an amazing day
so far so far so good for me i feel like
i woke up on the right side of the bed
that's how i felt yesterday and i woke
up a little before my alarm so i wasn't
so clumped the clamped when i woke up
bruno and i had a nice walk this morning
my hair went into a bun with ease you
know it's the small things
it really is i feel that i feel that way
it's like
i know it's going to be a good day with
my eyelashes which i sleep really hard
they just wake up and they're like in a
million different directions
if when i curl them and mascara them
they're all like uniformly working
together to you know make me look good
that's my like true sign it's gonna be a
good day yeah i listened to evermore
while i got ready
i'm enjoying it more and more
forevermore
and yeah i just the weather's really
nice there's a huge nor'easter coming
this week so one
prepare yourselves and two i feel like
this is the calm before the storm so
it's like a really beautiful day
bracing us for what's next yeah um
today's like a good day for me but not a
great day because i'm going to the
dentist for the first time
ben asked me last night before we went
to bed when was the last time i went to
the dentist
and i actually could not remember i want
to say like seven years maybe
and it's just gross so i'm going for a
checkup and a cleaning and i think i
need a night guard
you'll find out maybe some head gear i
think that's what you need
invisalign like i just want all the
different i need invisible
keys and i need you she's going to my
dentist i need you to pick up my
invisalign that i ordered
seven months ago i actually can if you
want me to um that's crazy that you
didn't go to the dentist for so long and
on the one hand like
you should have but on the other hand
like you go on the dent you go to the
dentist like on a need basis
and my teeth like hurt every six months
and it's like they need a deep cleaning
no see that's the thing it's like i have
no problems with my teeth except now i'm
feeling a lot of tension in my jaw i'm
feeling like i might have tmj
i'm also feeling like um
it's time i've just been hesitant to go
to the doctor because my wisdom teeth
like grew in and there was enough
spageman for them and
there was no problem and i just know
like dentists like want them out
and i'm just not in the mood to be like
convinced into getting my wisdom teeth
taken out because mark my words
i will not get them taken out it because
if i'm going in for surgery
at any time soon it's either for
liposuction or to get my tonsils taken
out
i hear you i actually really need my
tonsils taken out my dentist
she loves to take out wisdom teeth and
i'm going to your dentist and it ain't
happening that'll be
firm my words my wisdom teeth do not
bother me they never have i didn't even
know that they grew in there was just so
much space for them
i'm one of the lucky one no my wisdom
teeth grew in and they hurt but then
they grew
and then i switched dentists and she
convinced me that i should have them out
because they'll cause like all these
other issues throughout life and i
already have like
very sensitive teeth and so i was like i
don't need more issues so i got my
wisdom teeth
out that was a fun time in a lot of ways
you know um what's the type of like um
religion where like you don't believe in
medicine
i i remember uh listening to an
interview where ellen said she grew up
in a family that like
i think it's all called like christian
science or something where it's like you
don't take advil or something i don't
know
well that's like in the book that i read
educated but that was like a very
extreme
right and so i feel like in a lot of
ways like i'm very into modern medicine
like i literally take advil
the second i wake up i love thomas
you're probably medicine i'm so pro
especially over the counter like
that aisle is just a dream like i have
had so many experiences like saved by
pepto-bismol
but sometimes i'm like really wary of
modern medicine like
i feel like there's so many superfluous
surgeries these days like just for money
like
even getting your tonsils taken out the
fact that it's like now routine for like
teenagers like i just don't think that's
necessary you know yeah
i hear you i think it's good to question
stuff but we were talking yesterday
because we're like so excited about the
vaccine
and i guess like and part of me has just
been like thinking
like for so long it's like what are the
anti-vaxxers gonna do because
i'm like they have to get it but you
were like no no like that's this is
literally their time to shine like yes
they're not gonna get it
and i'm like that's just so crazy and
there's all these people being like
you're gonna get a second
head if you and like because i put up a
video on my instagram story and people
are like
yeah she's feeling fine now but wait
until she has a snake growing out of her
neck like
people are being so crazy and and we
read the funniest comment
someone commented on our youtube
yesterday you guys are going to get the
vaccine
like yes and people were commenting back
like
have you ever had a piece of american
cheese have you ever done drugs that you
bought from
someone's trunk have you ever had a
mcdonald's chicken nugget no and now
that i think about it like of all the
[ __ ] i put in my body
like me to be worried about the vaccine
would be the true like the pinnacle of
hypocrisy like i literally drink like
fountain soda
morning noon and night like i have done
all different types of drugs like i
like who the [ __ ] do i think i am to say
no to pfizer 100
sorry controversial statement coming out
but yes uh
the second i can i saw your video you po
oh margo posted another video
osm dancing healthcare workers dancing
it's just it's a bright time and i will
not let the anti-vaxxers
get me down i'm pretty sure yesterday is
being called v-day
oh that's cute for vaccine day but i
have i know this is like i know i'm
overthinking it but i have
like more concerns like what are the
anti-vaxxers like gonna do
not get it right i haven't heard from
any like anti-vaxxers but i think there
will be people who opt out
no i know but like the anti-vaccine
community oh are they gonna
like get together it just you know this
is gonna be a controversial statement
but like part of me
understands where they're coming from in
their anti-vaccine sentiment when it
comes to like their babies
you know there are certain cases like i
can see how someone could like be wary
of vaccines for their newborn baby like
i actually could see that even when
michaela was getting all these vaccines
i'm like
oh my god but she's such a baby like all
these things but now it's like no we're
in a pandemic like an order for the
world to be saved like everyone needs to
get the
the vaccine but like they're not going
to do it and that just freaks me out
but at a certain point like it's about
personal agency like if you get the
vaccine you're covering yourself and
you're covering the people around you so
if someone else doesn't get it like
that's on them
it's right and i guess anti-vaxxers like
really only hang out with anti-vaxxers
you never know that's true you never
know who around you could be an
anti-vaxxer
but that's what's so great about the
vaccine like if you want it
get it and you're good to go i want it i
got it
i want it i like it um so the
bachelorette was on that site
yes and we are going to talk about it
but i just feel like
two weeks in a row now this week and
next week we have two two-hour episodes
that is 16 hours in two weeks which is
so absurd
and so disrespectful right it's not
right it's down and this year has been
hard enough and you're going to finish
it out with 16 hours and you know what
i would be that's not correct math eight
two and two and two and two yeah yeah
yeah eight okay
still a lot yeah no it feels like six no
but see the thing is like now it doesn't
feel like a lot because it's not 16.
but all i'm saying is like i would be
willing to put up with that like i would
be annoyed but if it was like really
juicy like
last night's episode was such
unbelievable trash like
i could not believe that i was allotting
brain cells to it i was literally doing
a million other things well
i don't even know what happened the
mental law was such and i hate to keep
using this reference because i feel like
it might be losing its value but it was
the true definition of loser on loser
crime
no no that is still as pungency okay
because i'm worried because
some sometimes we come up with words and
we like bury them and we just murder
them because we use them so much
but it was truly so many losers just
committing crimes to other losers
and it was really hard for me to stomach
and it's hard to care when it's a loser
on loser crime that's exactly what it is
i could not care yeah we'll we'll get
into it i thought like
i can make some interesting and uh
obsessions uh but for the most part yeah
it's just it's getting tough
i actually don't know if i'm capable of
making one interesting observation from
last night's episode
seeing as how not one interesting thing
happened yeah except
the date with plague more than i tag
studios yeah when he was like talking in
his interview beforehand like just
trying so hard so so hard i was like
they're saying it i'm glad that he
shouldn't even wait till the dinner
portion me too
send him home while the sun was still up
to be honest like
after coming off of sunday night
watching the real housewives of potomac
which i've now
just i watched it on sunday but i've
been like recapping and reading
so much like commentary on it which is
being widely regarded as
the best read in housewives reunion
history since season six of atlanta
where porsha said that
incredibly disgusting thing to kenya
about a guy [ __ ] in a cup so he can
get a medium pizza and a coke
like they're saying that that that
monique's um yes
yes performance is just as maybe if not
better phaedra season six so i've just
been like living
in this potomac bubble and just have to
go and watch this
this reunion on mental all which was so
everyone was missing there was no
audience and it was just
losers being losers yeah i totally agree
so we'll dedicate as little time to it
as possible we actually have some really
great stories today that i look forward
to diving into fabulous and aside from
that it's just
oh yesterday we did a patreon episode
best of 2020 claudia and i each sat down
did a little research on our data
analytics from the year
the best shows movies music
albums toast episodes celebrities of
2020 all of our favorites
and we also like went down memory lane
and started talking about all the shows
that we watched this year that we have
completely
forgotten about it was really emblematic
of how long this year has been because
i'm about to blow everyone's mind and
let you know let me remind you
do you know what show came out in 2020
not only it came out we watched it went
viral and like all the people became
famous
that whole thing and cancelled and
canceled
cheer cheer on netflix remember that was
this
[ __ ] year okay crazy that's so crazy
so we're just taking a trip
down memory lane of 2020 at patreon.com
we have three more episodes that'll get
you through while we are off
starting on monday of next week and then
we'll be back the first monday of the
new year
so we're going to miss you but we're
going to be having a g.a.t a good ass
time miss you want to kiss you yeah
we'll always be creating content though
because that's
what we do so without without
i guess i don't know it's hard to know
because thco isn't here no he's getting
a haircut
he's just you know moving and grooving
he's so booked and busy
ever since that pete davidson photo went
viral like everybody's calling
gma the view today's show it's exciting
he actually got his own publicist you
know i guess like the work that i was
doing as a momager was
inadequate yeah and the work that i was
doing as a brand manager and he hired
external people
you know what he deserves the best and
and he'll see like he'll come crawling
back of course
nobody looks after you like your own
mother
hundred percent so without further ado
i guess it could maybe probably be time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning total oh [ __ ]
yes guys here get the door ooh he has a
delivery
it's a big box of rdh i got you guys
because i would be rdh remiss
devastated and heartbroken if i didn't
let you know that today's episode very
appropriately since i'm going to the
dentist is brought to you by bruce
and i know dr rebecca is going to be
like oh my god claudia your teeth look
amazing what have you been doing and i
will say dr rebecca
i've been brushing no two smiles are the
same but every healthy smile is truly
perfect
and that's why you gotta bruce what is
bruce
it is the only electric toothbrush that
you need it is the best on the market
and the most reasonably priced
and the most beautiful because i love
keeping it on my counter it has this
like magnetic base it's super sleek
i have it in pink but it comes in other
colors and it's really just like
the gift that keeps on giving to your
breath to your oral health to your
tongue
just fabulous bruce cleans your teeth at
31 000 movements a minute
manual toothbrushes tap out at just 300.
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up for manual
and some of them can do a good job but
they cost over two hundred dollars
bruce is delivering premier sonic wave
technology without the markups that big
electric toothbrushes tack on
the bruce electric toothbrush kit which
is what we got
includes three extra brush heads a
magnetic charging station and a sleek
travel case and the brush includes six
cleaning modes
the daily white gentle gum max and
tongue modes
and it has a smart timer with a quad
pacer and it has a four week
battery life so i always leave mine on
the charger but i guess
i don't need to no and now when you go
away you can take it without the charger
and
you're good for four weeks oh i didn't
think about that um they also have a
refill subscription where you can get
three replacement brushes
shipped every six months for just 18 and
they give back because with every bruce
refill shipped bruce donates oral care
supplies through a reason to smile
so if you want to get 15 off your brush
order plus express
free shipping december 16 through
december 20th perfect for the holiday
season you got to use the promo code
toast at bruce.com
that's b-r-u-u-s-h.com they are
guaranteeing arrival before christmas so
you can try it 90 days risk-free and get
a 2-year warranty
at b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com promo code toast
love it i mean look at my smile her
smile bruce sells itself
yeah no it really does and i really do
think that she's going to be so
impressed with your teeth i think and
that's why you haven't had needed to go
to the dentist it's true
um okay first story some big news of the
day little mixes
jessie officially is leaving the group
this news broke yesterday while we were
live like
knowing that it would just devastate us
and that we needed the time to process
it before we could deliver the news to
you but jesse nelson has officially left
little mix after nine amazing years
together the group put out a statement
saying after nine amazing years together
jesse has made the decision to leave
little mix
this is an incredibly sad time for all
of us but we are fully supportive of
jessie
we love her very much and agree that it
is so important that she does what is
right for her mental health and
well-being
we are still very much enjoying our
little mix journey and the three of us
are not ready for it to be over
so this statement gave me everything you
needed like i'm so
happy for jesse that she's putting
herself first and taking herself out of
a situation that's not what's best for
her but i'm also so happy that the other
three girls sound like they're committed
to staying in the band and giving us the
little mix that we know and love yeah so
a lot of people are
comparing this statement to the
statements of former bands past fifth
harmony one direction
um and are they similar no but it is
like
feels like history might be repeating
itself and it's for some people they
think it could be like the start of the
end but i agree the statement was very
hopeful
and i actually feel like the band could
go on
and it's not about jesse but now it's
about the other girls like mental health
because i feel like this is most similar
to one direction whereas like zane
wanted out and they were happy to let
him go
yeah and the band existed without him
but then it was like
the boys were just like over the the
machine
it wasn't even about them and i feel
like little mix actually is like a
really healthy
i mean i don't know them but i feel like
a healthy balance as a little mix stand
like i feel really good
about the girls in the band i feel like
they like being in the band i feel like
they're friends
i feel like they don't feel like one of
them should be the star and do a solo
like that was very
clear from the beginning and fifth
harmony like yeah i don't feel those
those familiar tensions that you get
with the band so i think with the three
of them
i'm just taking that sentence that last
sentence and like riding that and being
like if
if they truly like continue to be little
mix three members for a number of years
like that works for me
and i hope that jessie finds what she's
looking for 100
the only thing is that like i think what
made little mix so unique to
other girl bands is like their extreme
talent vocally and how they were always
doing like four part harmonies and
you need a fourth for a fourth part
harmony as a as a fan i can deal with a
three-part harmony that's good enough
for me it's not as dynamic but yes and
also they do have that
show that like little mix show and maybe
like they'll cast a fourth member oh
that would be crazy that would be really
interesting
and i would watch a show like that and i
and i'm open to all possibilities as
long as little mix stays together
i just want to say like i want little
like i will
move and groove with the changes of
little mix it's just like so sad how
like
bands like girl groups and boy bands
have just like this
history and stigma of like almost always
breaking up like why
and what's a band that you think boys to
men has really lasted the test of time i
think
bands that first of all all these fans
that you're mentioning came together on
a talent show they're not
childhood friends in sync backstreet
boys okay actually
boys are still together we're talking
about one direction and fifth harmony
they came together on
talent shows so they're the machines
putting them together and then i think
with bands like insync
you get that like one person is the
bigger star than the others justin
timberlake but also i think when
they these bands are started when these
people are teenagers
you know the machine sort of takes
advantage of them and then they resent
the band
you know they feel like there's so many
bands that are like adult bands you know
arrow smith like when you're adults
being able to make the shots for
yourself i think that it's easier to
stay in the band and have that agency
but i think when you're a child
it's easy to feel taken advantage about
because you are being taken advantage of
and you blame the banding you just want
out from the toxic situation
yeah well you know what um no it's a
good example i feel like a healthy band
is miron5 100 and because they're adults
yeah they're adults it's actually a
really good point
um also i feel like one of the books
that we read for the redheads this year
the unraveling of cassidy holmes is
about the dissolution of a girl band so
i feel like having read that
it gives me like a totally different
perspective and maybe i would have
reacted to this news differently if i
hadn't read that book
but like one of the members left as she
needed to and like i just wanted the
world to be kind to her so i just want
the world to be kind to jesse and i
think they are i think the little mix
fans are like really nice people
i do um i just have to say like not in
any way to make this about me but i did
call this several years ago yeah
no and i mean it always comes back to
you as it should and it also always
comes back to the redheads as you should
and it always comes back to the toast
or whatever it is i think i actually
said it for the first time on the
morning breath like
i've just been i've i had the you know
esteemed privilege of seeing them
perform in a very intimate concert when
i was an intern like
eight years ago and i felt a dynamic was
off with the girls and jessie
and i said if they ever break up or if
any of them were ever to leave it would
be jesse
and here we go i hate to be right i do
but yeah it happens all the time just
another thing
2020 has taken from us so but it's a
positive for jesse so that's how i'm
going to look at it and it's a positive
because i still have little mix so why
am i complaining
yeah no i think we're fine i think we're
going to be fine
speaking of breath throwbacks zach was
watching football last night
and the announcer said the name bradley
bozeman
do you know what that is of course and i
was like opposed
to his girlfriend when he won the
college football thing
and then they came on our show they came
on our show he made it to the nfl
yeah he's in he was on tv last night
they they came on our show like via um
skype and it was like a horrible
connection so i don't even know what
they said but we were so excited
to have them on their video went viral
when they got engaged it was so
pure it just took me back to a different
time yeah oh my god bradley bozeman i'm
so glad he made it to the end yeah
nicki are still going shawn thank god
did they get married yes oh my god when
i googled him it was like bradley and
wife nikki oh man
so cute so cute i just thought that was
like a fun memory also
i happened to have been watching
football as well last night because
there was like some big game it was
the baker mayfield's against the lamar
jacksons and oh that was football
what oh the way you were talking about
it i thought it was a fight
you mean like a yeah yeah just one one
on one no no no it was football
um and ben was explaining to me like
lamar jackson is like
the most amazing quarterback and yada
yada but he was like missing
because he was cramping and he like i
saw him they cut to the footage of him
like running out of the field to the
locker room and i'm like
i'm sorry to this man but he has to make
a duty like that is obviously what's
going on and then i was reading things
on the internet like everyone thinks he
was like making a duty
because he was running with like his ass
cheeks like clenched and you know that
run we all know it's like a waddle
almost and you know what i made me
really think like
about the stories we don't know about
about like professional athletes
performers it's like
you perform so many shows you play so
many games like human nature like you
are bound to
your your game or your performance is
bound to coincide with the bowel
movement right 100
and i think we should normalize taking
breaks for a ballot movement 100
i was just thinking like i mean i i only
went on one tour and i did have diarrhea
in houston like i'm not gonna lie so
it's like
by probability like the math it's like
katy perry has to have diarrhea
yeah shawn mendes yeah and you also like
some people might get nervous before
they go on stage their stomach drops
yeah if you ever wanna um like stop
being attracted to someone just imagine
them having diarrhea because they just
have like the mental image of shawn
mendes like sweaty on the toilet like
like not feeling good and like his
stomach really really hurts and like
he's starting to sweat and then he is
like explaining
like he would be a baby about it yeah no
no 100 and like i know what i'm like
when i'm in a lot of pain on on
on the toilet like literally i'm a
nightmare and i'm acting so weird and i
start sweating
um and so if you're ever wanting to stop
if you're crushing on someone like
someone who's toxic for you
just picture like your toxic ex having
crazy diarrhea
that'll do the trick in two seconds yeah
no it definitely does or
you know you can also picture them
waiting in a line do you know what i
mean like
doing without doing a backpack doing
yeah doing like
awkward human things like waiting in
line and then like eating while standing
up you know like
certain things yeah you can picture them
doing that'll make you really like
unattractive
make them unattractive to you i i
completely agree i think that's some of
the best advice you've ever given
that's what i do here on the holiday
season on the holiday season
i'm giving the gift of advice got it
okay um next story
some lizzo news lizzo is defending going
on a 10-day juice cleanse
lizzo responded to backlash after
revealing she went on a 10-day juice
cleanse
she shared her daily results after
drinking green juice every day in a
video posted to tiktok on monday
she said so i drank a lot and ate a lot
of food and [ __ ] up my stomach in
mexico so i decided to do jj smith's 10
day smoothie cleanse
while she struggled at times lizzo said
she was never super hungry
and decided to complete the cleanse
because she was just wanting to stress
eat and do things that were kind of
self-harming
showing off her results on the day of
the final detox she said i'm going to
give you a
full twirl i feel amazing and i think
it's great to do a reset
to your stomach especially when you deal
with gastrointestinal issues like i do
but i think i look [ __ ] great too so
period but several tick tock users were
slamming the singer people on tick tock
are so unhappy about
absolutely everything yeah calling the
body image advocate out for promoting a
dangerous diet they said quote
not lizzo doing toxic diet culture one
person wrote
with another adding this is not the kind
of stuff you should be promoting
then lizzo put out a statement um
defending her personal choice she said
as you know i would normally be so
afraid and ashamed to post things like
this online because i feel like as a big
girl
people just expect if you're doing
something for health you're doing it for
a dramatic weight loss and that's not
the case
she said in in reality november stressed
me the [ __ ] out i drank a lot i ate a
lot of spicy things and that [ __ ] up
my stomach
and i wanted to reverse it to get back
to where i was she said my sleep has
improved my hydration my
inner peace my mental stability
my [ __ ] body my [ __ ] skin the
whites of my eyes like i feel and look
like a bad [ __ ] and that's it i'm a big
girl who did a smoothie detox
and i wanted to share that with you guys
i got exactly what i wanted out of it
and every big girl should do whatever
the [ __ ] they want with their body
okay every person not even just big
girls but i agree it's like
lizzo just can't win because on her
videos where she's just like being
herself the comments are [ __ ]
atrocious like
lose weight like so disgusting okay so
now she's doing a cleanse and you're
unhappy like
i can't nobody can win just do whatever
you want and you know what it's like
okay whether or not you believe in diet
culture why don't we just all believe in
the culture of letting everyone do what
the [ __ ] they want i completely agree i
loved her statement defending it i
i love that she didn't apologize like i
actually want to try this juice cleanse
now
i don't know because that's exactly what
i need no i feel like but you know what
ben came in the other day
and he was like he really has been on
like a bender like i'm just like eating
it no that's exciting
and he we got home from his parents and
we had like a hanukkah feast and he was
like honestly like i just do not feel
that i have not been feeling good like
i really need to cut down he's like
should i do a cleanse i'm like well
sure and he literally of course didn't
know how to do a cleanse went into
the um bar cart where we have this like
lemon juice
and put it in a water bottle and like
drink the whole thing um
which has nothing to do with lizzo but i
just thought was a funny anecdote but at
the same time it's like
[ __ ] off yeah no it's like [ __ ] off no
and it's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] off no and i feel like
normalized people doing whatever the
[ __ ] they want first of all but
i just feel like we just need to have
acceptance for all like all ways of
of eating whether that is dieting too
you know by the way whether you're pro
diet culture
anti-diet culture whether you think diet
is now like a bad word
and by the way i think i am the pinnacle
of anti-diet culture like i just don't
believe in any of that stuff
but i will literally never ever ever
ever ever
shame or talk about someone else wanting
to go on a diet that is called a free
country
you can do whenever you want like i'm
just
i i don't even want to say i'm like
anti-diet culture because then that
means i'm
again i take a stand no it's just like
my personal choice is i don't come about
diets
you go on diets should i kill you no no
it's just like this whole culture of
like
people doing things that you don't
necessarily agree with like let's ruin
their lives
but necessarily agree with for
themselves they're doing that only on
their own they're not hurting anybody
else like they're not shoving
you down your personal opinions on other
people like
take a seat so i don't believe in that
so i just that that's actually
my whole philosophy on life in general
like and even when it comes to like
politics like
i just can't understand why other people
care what other people do
i completely agree you don't think being
gay is cool don't be gay
like that's just my philosophy and if we
could all this is my
this is my this is my moment if we could
all just
get out of each other's vaginas and like
stop like looking at your neighbor like
just
[ __ ] off you do you let everyone else do
them
and there would be wall piece i swear to
god this is like this is a philosophy
that's going to change the world and
it's called
mining your own goddamn business agreed
and by the way this smoothie
detox sounds great i'm going to do it
thanks elizabeth no because that's
literally how i feel
and i've actually never done a cleanse
before because i feel like i don't
trust any of them i don't know about any
of them necessarily but like lizzo
endorsing one like makes me feel like oh
maybe like
i should do that i've never done a
cleanse and you know what i've never
even wanted to do a cleanse and that's
something i'm really proud of
no i like i need a cleanse i keep going
like this on my in my spare time because
i just feel like so bloated in my chin
okay we look fine so that's why i need a
cleanse sure that's why i wore my hair
up to pull it all back
next story a little church drama
selena gomez quits hill song amid carl
lenses cheating scandal
now this is like kind of confusing so
listen no not it's pretty
straightforward but the implications i'm
curious
the pop star has moved on from the
celebrity favored mega church in the
wake
in the wake of a recent cheating scandal
involving embattled pastor carl lentz
the daily mail reported on monday quote
selena considers
herself a christian the daily mail
reported citing sources from australia's
daily telegraph
she says she has a close relationship
with god and she believes this is not
how god wants us to operate
she's disillusioned gomez um was the
former friend
of hillsong of karl lentz and
at one point adored carl but doesn't
want anything to do with
hillsong anymore but this like makes me
curious if she's leaving like in defense
of carl or because
you know what i mean because it's like
he's out ready to see me one more time
it's a really confusing story based on
like a source from australia's daily
telegraph but that
she says she has a close relationship
with god and she believes this is not
how god wants us to operate she's
disillusioned
i don't oh you know what that's a really
good point like we don't want to operate
what
ex-community ex-communicating someone
who made a mistake is that what she's
saying no or like
that mistake that hill song like allowed
these things to happen i don't know
the insider said at one stage she adored
carl she
his daughter at laura and justin were a
team really close she used to hang out
with the founders daughter-in-law
esther now she doesn't want anything to
do with hillsong anymore
but so is it like so carl is not
hillsong right
so it's curious i didn't even know that
she was still a member i thought
is justin still a member um
i'm not i think so yeah so i feel like
um
they really both could still be members
it says that haley has unfollowed carl
on instagram
wow her and austin were a thing which
before
it had it was debunked i fully thought
was like the cutest couple of all times
no i was like
here for it but she also has been like
with this guy jeff dye they went to cabo
together and it was comedian
yeah so she went to dinner in nashville
with justin anderson
craig and austin okay and then they were
like
on instagram live dancing things looked
flirty between austin and kristen
people were speculating that they were
like an item and then kristen just um
posted to her instagram story along
side of video of her rolling her eyes
and she said i didn't realize i was
allowed to have friends that are guys
so she's just saying that her and austin
are just friends but um
i'm sorry this response is like kind of
lame yeah
it's like sorry like we're just matching
you with such eligible bachelors oh i
wish that was my biggest problem no i
feel like
that would have been a an interesting
coupling that like i wouldn't expect for
her by the way 100
and i would have fully supported even
though i'm like taking madison side so i
don't want
like austin to be like winning in the
post relationship era
and madison said the funniest thing she
said um because
someone like commented asking like her
thoughts she said yeah trust me if he
was with her he wouldn't be sending me
songs at midnight
bless and then she told entertainment
she told entertainment tonight i think
he's trying to get
under my skin which is fine and like
honestly if he can pull her go for it
knock yourself out i'd be shocked
oh my god lol i like i'm so torn on like
the austin and madison
front like as much as i no
i'm supporting them both i'm team
pringle your team pringles wow
i'm supporting them both no me too 100 i
mean
i'm so conflicted on whether or not i
think they should be together are they
otp
but at some point it does get a little
tired you know it's like get over it
yeah
and like at some point maybe they need
years apart austin needs to like
grow up grow his brand and be the man
that madison needs
yeah and a man that patricia approves of
for madison yeah but i hate to like look
at the world through patricia's eyes me
too but i actually think of all the
things and all the opinions and all the
fights patricia has started
i think the only thing i actually really
agree with her on and from the beginning
was that like austin was not like good
enough for madison
yeah i feel you yeah okay our fifth and
final story is
probably my favorite story of the day um
if you haven't seen this video please go
treat yourself
just google smokey robinson um but yes
smokey robinson doesn't know what
hanukkah is
sort of i think that's a little
misleading so smokey robinson was asked
to do a cameo
for this guy for i guess his parents he
got his mom a video she loves smokey
robinson
and no she grew up on the same street as
him oh yeah and he wanted smokey
robinson to wish her a happy hanukkah he
spelled hanukkah
c-h-a-n-u-k-a-h and at the end of it
like it's a long video and then smokey
robinson goes oh and happy chanukah
i don't know what chanukah is but happy
new year but your son wanted me to wish
you for you so whatever that is
enjoy chanukah yeah it's the funniest
thing
it's really precious it's so precious
it's just like a hilarious precious
video and on the one hand it's like he
doesn't know what hanukkah is but on the
other hand i want to give him the
benefit of the doubt and say
he's never seen it spelled with a ch i
mean there are two spellings but at the
end of the day like they literally look
exactly the same
and when i first thought i'm like oh my
god this video is precious and then part
of me was like okay wait like also like
how do you like exist in america and
like not know what hanukkah is
yeah so i i want to believe like maybe
it was just the spelling but if it's
true that like
how i don't know spikey robinson must be
like 75 years old maybe older
if you've lived this long and you don't
know what hanukkah is like right that's
what i'm saying i think it's slightly
spelling
and even it's impossible but it's like i
can't judge this because that is
something that i would do like
doc's tuned that's true that's like just
seeing a word
knowing like thinking for sure i know
how it's pronounced and then like my
whole world being rocked
that's true and it's like i knew what a
dachshund was but i never knew that doc
shoon was
toxic and that's the same thing he might
know what hanukkah is but doesn't know
that chanukah is hanukkah has smokey
spoken like
his statement was not included in this
article at the time of publicly the
video went so viral like
he has to respond yeah honestly his
cameo booking numbers are probably so
up now yeah i mean speaking of cameras
and i'm jealous because i joined by the
way literally our conversation yesterday
about kevin baumgartner from the office
making a million dollars
in cameo bookings this year inspired me
to join cameo for the holiday season i
just wanted to i'd get so many dms of
like
people's boyfriends being like oh like
can i can you give me a video you're not
on cameo so i just thought i would do it
i've never done it before you used to do
it i used to do it i think you're going
to be great at it you think
yeah i think that you have all the
makings of a cameo star i
just um like oh i got i got some
bookings oh my god
yay i just uploaded um like my little
video
i'm very excited about it so if you guys
are looking for a cameo from claude
you can get one on cameo or tell your
significant other that that would be a
great gift thanks jax for the promo
you're welcome i think you're gonna be
great me too and i just want to make a
million dollars like a mountain gardener
yeah and i i mean i'm just gonna give it
my all right i was thinking about making
theo a cameo
yes and i just wasn't sure like the
logistics of like how i would like
really make him talk
you know yeah well you could use one of
those like animating apps but i do think
you have to film the cameo videos like
in
an app so i was just like thinking of
you know how i could exploit theo for
money because you know he's costing me
an arm and a leg well
you guys could be like claudia and theo
on cameo yeah
it's definitely gonna be a doctor and
mrs thing oh cute yeah
um so let's dive into our tv recap right
yes let's which is brought to you by
love book online
love book is a personalized gift that
helps people express feelings that might
be difficult to say out loud
most customers use a love book to
revisit their fondest memories or to
list the reasons why they love someone
love books are completely customizable
and people can use them however they
like
users create characters that look just
like themselves and the recipient
with all the features that make them
unique you can even choose your favorite
hairstyles and outfits
customers have the option to personalize
each page as much as they'd like
they also love book also offers an
express option where you can create
a complete book in just a few minutes
love books are the perfect gift for any
occasion but especially for
anniversaries birthdays and christmases
this is such a cute idea i feel like um
of all the
the things you can get someone like
certain people just require you they
demand more of you in terms of
sentimentality and i think a love book
is such a creative way to tell someone
that you love them they come out
so cute and the characters like with all
the little hairstyles and the outfits
like end up looking just like you and
it's really really thoughtful and it's a
perfect gift
for someone in your life who like a
material item just like won't cut like
it's it needs to be bigger and better
whether it's like grandma
husband wife mom
so if you want to visit
lovebookonline.com toast
you can receive a special 20 discount
just for our listeners
but you have to use slash
lovebookonline.com
to get that 20 discount make sure you
get your orders in because this is a
perfect thing to get for someone for the
holidays
yes very perfect maybe i'll get one for
you okay
that'll be sweet little jacks and little
jackson claudia
and their magic cigarettes and their
magic microphones oh that's cute
oh my god that's so cute um okay tv
recap like
you talk because i literally do not have
one thing to say it was such a
letdown of an episode the first hour was
the um
the real episode and then the second
hour was the just phrase
yeah i i like okay just you say what you
okay the real episode so
blake went home after like he tried to
pull out all the stops
for his date but he also just thought
like him being himself was just like
enough to win the bachelor and maybe
like a few years ago
that would have been the case but like
with tasha you have to be firing out of
every cylinder he just like
when he got ready for the date and he
was being like interviewed during the
date he just like wanted it
too bad 100 and he was like trying to
like
it like squeeze his shoe like his foot
into the black slipper
and it wasn't his slipper yeah and it
was like he wanted it so bad not because
he wanted tasha so bad yeah he wanted it
so bad because he just wanted to make it
to the next round and i don't know how
he like didn't
die of awkwardness when they were doing
that tantric sex thing and like
literally looking so close into each
other
and tasha was just like i could feel the
cringiness coming from tasia
yeah i just feel like a rule of thumb if
you're on the bachelor and you get a
sign in the tantric sex state like
the lead doesn't like you yeah so true
because they want to make it awkward
they don't want to make it
yeah it's not like where you're actually
gonna fall in love and like that's gonna
it's
supposed to be like a funny awkward
thing yeah and it's just like
for us here at the morning toast like
blake really had a huge fall from grace
huge we loved him yeah no i just i
thought he was so cute and then
no and then he was like so excited to
like bring her home and it's like you
actually don't know her you do not know
this girl you know and so it's like you
would be having like
your parents win her over for you like
stranger over put in some work 100
percent and honestly i think part of the
reason why
blake had such a fall from grace moment
is because he really started to look
like ed
you know what i'm sure during the mental
health i thought ed was kind of funny
and i think that scene of him and chris
harrison like drinking wine
is like funny hysterical i'm kind of
here for ed i feel like he would be a
really great addition to paradise
because he's kind of like
older and takes himself seriously but
it's just a different vibe from the
other guys who are like young thirst
monsters that's true that's true you
know
um so after blake got sent home she just
like ran she was like being a little
dramatic with all the crying
yeah ran in to send riley home which i
didn't really understand like
why she waited to send certain people
home at the rose ceremony but riley got
special treatment like why don't you
just
go through them all that night i don't
know it was weird but she was happy i
liked that she switched
it up didn't see it coming riley went
home then we had a rose ceremony and no
one bennett went home
i really liked noah and i know that he
was like he was giving me like due to
two different vibes sometimes i thought
he was a douche and then sometimes i
thought he was like a loser like i
couldn't tell which one he was i
couldn't tell which one he was and when
bennett like really just kind of
eviscerated him at the mental wall he
had they were going back and forth i
thought noah was like standing his
ground but then when bennett
when he was like you said i was division
in three of the categories and then it
was like
i was actually four and everyone started
laughing at him like i actually felt a
little sad for him
um and i agree he kind of reminds me of
like dean i feel like just like a cool
younger guy i feel like if he goes
yes oh that's paradise that's who he'll
be
but i just feel like he found himself in
this mess and
i actually think that him and bennett
are both like fine people yeah and i i
thought bennett performed really well at
mental wall and came off kind of genuine
like when he apologized to noah
i i could accept that at face value and
the fact that noah couldn't just be like
thanks man i just was like okay that's a
little immature
i just like i just can't get myself to
care about these people like it's so
crazy
i know and like the fight was just so
manufactured and so [ __ ] stupid where
the [ __ ] was jason
right they like they talked about it was
it um
who was talking about him just like
totally ed
eviscerated him yeah like was like fake
phony blah blah blah
and it's like i actually agree with you
but chase is not there to defend himself
so it's actually not wrong
to talk about him that was weird so
don't bring him up if you can't invite
him to mental well period nobody like
even remember chase and we didn't need
to talk about it no we didn't need to
talk about any of them like there were
some guys sitting there like the guy who
was a boy band manager
who somebody called like the one
direction skinny jean wearing guy and
that was so funny i'm like what are you
doing here like
why are you here but jason's not and i
know why easy wasn't invited because
there's an investigation into him
someone made allegations of sexual
assault so i know why he wasn't there
but it's like the fact that all these
other guys were there that i literally
have never seen in my life
yeah it was really really random and
there was just like
not much to understand especially
because we're like trying to make a
mountain like they were trying to make
substance out of nothing yeah and i feel
like tasha like as always just like
saved the day queen and just like made
it seem like so much more
had substance than it was because there
was really nothing there but she just
like gave everyone
so much respect and i also feel like
everyone in that room is in love with
her
like the first person yeah everyone
everyone in that room like all of those
men like
are genuinely upset that they missed
that
missed out on her and in so many ways i
feel like tasha wasn't given a fair
chance this season
one because of the claire debacle where
it's like she was robbed of like four
weeks
two because this like simulation they're
living in
are they gonna do the hometowns in the
resort i i think they're going to bring
the families to the resort yeah
and then the fantasy suites in different
corners of the resort like it's just
so weird like it's just it's a
simulation and of course
honestly when she was crying so much i'm
like she's being dramatic but it's like
she's in a prison
of this hotel like of course emotions
are heightened i understand
but it's like in so many ways this is
such a fake season and i feel like
whoever she ends up with which i have my
theory is who it is
um i think it's zach okay cause now
here's our final four ben zach
ivan brendan or ben
no i don't think it's ben really the
thing is it's like tasha gives so much
of
her soul to like all these guys that i'm
like she's in love with brandon and i
love brendan but something he's i think
he might be like a little too
introverted for her that's the only
thing i don't really see them like
having amazing conversation i feel like
tashas like pull stuff out of him
but opposites attract yeah but like when
you're
as effervescent as me and tasha are like
you want someone on your level
yeah and i feel like ben is like can
keep up and i really feel like zach is
like
he he was married before right yeah and
i just feel like they're on the same
level but then i feel like ivan i feel
like they have a really deep connection
ivan it reminds me of like rachel
lindsay or almost when jojo had like
such a good friendship with vinnie
remember
i feel like ivan and tatia are like such
good friends i don't get sexual energy
from them at all that's an interesting
call
and everyone loves ivan he's definitely
bachelor material
and the fact that he made it this far is
good for him in the future like maybe
you know after matt james's season will
get
uh an ivan season but i don't see them
like being in love i see them like
literally being like brother and sister
like best friends
that's interesting i feel like i could
argue why any of them might win
or why they wouldn't like i i don't feel
like there's a clear someone who doesn't
have any reasons why i can't see them
together
what do you like about zach like what
don't you see i just don't
like see i just feel like he's been a
winner like a front runner from the
beginning
for sure maybe i don't know but i
remember when they had those coins that
was him right yeah
he's just like always been cute yeah
okay i feel that
i don't know it'll be interesting at
least like we really don't know it's not
like
jordan and jojo right that's what i like
but
who does jimmy kimmel say ben i feel
like maybe oh maybe
ben or zach not that like jimmy kimmel
is like the end-all be-all but no but he
usually has a good
pulse right i just don't know how he
knows that like
yeah i like sometimes i remember i
accidentally spoiled ben
and susan for myself and said the winner
was lauren bushnell and i'm like who is
lauren bushnell like
i had never heard of her yet like i
literally didn't even notice her yeah
you only know lauren lane
that's true stan lauren lane um so all
in all
want mom yeah yep and so we'll see you
again tonight for the bachelor
and oh the bachelor because it's tuesday
like usually watch the bachelor
oh you know oh my god i forgot it's on
again tonight yeah
i'm sorry to break that news to you all
right you guys that's all we got for you
thank you so much
even the truckers for tasha didn't pull
didn't show up and you know what i
respect that because
they were like that mental i was nothing
of the sort thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning chose the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fastback stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
monday through friday ted on youtube
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up make sure to head over to
patreon.com morning toast so that
you have always have content even when
we're not here just talking a mile a
minute
um check out the redhead such fun times
great group of gals claudia's book girls
no
child dot com slash book sorry i just
like really forgot what i was going to
say you know
it happens and make sure to find us
wherever you find your podcast whether
that's spotify itunes stitch or public
video i already cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows leave a five star
review about beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day we will see you
tomorrow for
hump day goodbye
you